hello I'm Greg Sandler I'm a philosophy
professor and I'm also a producer of
popular YouTube videos that have helped
thousands of people study and understand
philosophy one of the series that I'm
most proud of and most excited about is
called half-hour Hegel here's my pitch
for you today I'd like to invite you to
become a patron of the half-hour Hegel
series by doing so you're going to be
supporting an innovative digital project
and you're going to be creating an
educational resource that's going to be
available for people who want to study
this difficult thinker and work for
years and perhaps even for generations
to come
I'll also offer you some some
interesting and enticing rewards as an
incentive for becoming a contributor now
at this point you might say what Hegel
or why Hegel why should we study this
guy he's you know somebody who's very
important in the history of philosophy
so if you if you want to have a good
understanding of the scope of philosophy
he's somebody who's worth studying but
there's more than that he is really one
of the Giants of the 19th century and of
continental European thought in general
his works are quite difficult to study
which is why a lot of people stay away
from them and he's not taught as often
as one might like but if you spend the
time to go through them especially if
you have a good guide you're gonna find
they're incredibly rich in ideas and
they teach you approaches to all sorts
of things that can be quite useful even
outside of the sphere of philosophy now
one of the key works of Hegel if you
only read one work by him I would say
you want to read the phenomenology of
spirit and that's what this half hour
Hegel project is about
CalFire Hegel is a project that I
undertook in order to make it possible
for people who don't necessarily have
the time to go to graduate school or to
acquire you know a complete
philosophical background to be able to
study Hegel's phenomenology of spirit
and what I've been doing using this
blackboard using my camera standing in
front with with pieces of chalk like
this is to go through Hegel's
phenomenology paragraph by paragraph
providing commentary and explanation for
the viewers and they can they can go
back to it whenever they like they can
use it to help them work through the
text I do it in half-hour installments
because that's a manageable chunk of
time and that's a manageable amount of
Haegele to study at one getting given
setting so far I've managed to shoot 45
installments I've uploaded them in my
youtube channel and offer them to the
general public who wants to study this
great work now if you're not amongst
that fairly rare group of people who
upon hearing me talk about Hegel
immediately said I gotta get in on this
you might be asking why should I
contribute why should I become a patron
and I'm gonna make the common good pitch
to you first what does this series doing
so half hour Hegel is providing a unique
digital resource that's designed to help
all types of people study this difficult
work the phenomenology of spirit by
making it accessible to them and I'm
making it available open access across
the internet worldwide as a sort of
public resource this is a model for the
future of the digital humanities this is
going to provide something that's going
to be around for years perhaps for
decades perhaps for generations
depending on what YouTube and Technology
become in the future but for the present
its producing something that really
hasn't been attempted up until now and
you can become part of that you can
become a supporter of that for those who
contribute and support projects like
this I think it's really the fitting
that there be some sort of rewards and
even recognition and I provide that you
can see on the side the sorts of things
that
have decided ought to go to my patrons
things as simple as a thank-you note or
at a higher level a copy of the
phenomenology the spirit with an
inscription by me to being involved in
online Q&A study sessions to one-on-one
tutorials and even the chance to select
some of the music for the videos or to
be mentioned as a patron on my blog and
at the end of the videos I'd love to see
you getting involved in this half-hour
hagel project and there's a number of
ways you can do that you can use the
free videos that I provide in order to
study Hangul and talk with other people
about that if you want to become a
patron of the project I've outlined how
to do that you just go to the patreon
page and decide what level you want to
pledge at ranging from as low as you
know a dollar if you want some sort of
reward all the way to the higher tiers
and whether you're going to become a
patron or not if you have any interest
in seeing these sorts of educational
resources being developed share this
video and my patreon page with others in
your social media who you think have an
interest in the intellectual life
[Music]